this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armouries museum in the uk which houses
a collection of
thousands of iconic weapons from
throughout history
and today he's going to be reacting to
the red light green light mission
from call of duty black ops cold war a
mission that showcases a fair few
quintessential guns from the cold war
period
albeit not always realistically i just
love the uh
the dazed stagger from being hit with an
anti-aircraft missile
just like shakes it off right over to
you jonathan
let's go
look at that monster reds could be
hiding anything inside
snap a picture also want to see this
okay pausing
so this this looks really cool and cold
war-esque with a giant concrete
um super villain looking building i
don't know how plausible
that building would be but i'm not an
architect the rifle is an interesting
one it's a very cold war
choice being a 1960s vintage
rifle or carbine actually have one so
this is the chinese type 63
but the key thing about it in terms of
reality versus
the game is that it is it is select fire
and it will
run fully automatic now obviously that
would cause some problems in the game
balance wise because why bother with an
ak if you've got this
as to it being a sniper well look very
sniper like does it
not something the typical cold warrior
would be running through the jungle or
the forest or whatever this is supposed
to be
with
you're welcome interesting press x to
not die style cut scene there
where the russian guard is being
disarmed
and the weapon that is pulled up and
used to kill him is not a tokarev
as we might expect it's not a makarov as
we might expect
it's an american cult 1911. so that's
very strange there must be some sort of
sophisticated mail order catalog system
going on in this particular facility
because that's a definitively iconically
american pistol
however here is one and this one which
you may not be able to see
the tiny marking is actually russian so
they did exist
in russia now what they'd be doing in
use at this
time period i don't know but whether by
accident or by
some knowledge of the developers it's
not actually implausible for there to be
a 1911 in russia
so we've done the usual let's grab the
first weapon we see that looks cool
thing because that's what you do in a
first person shooter and it does look
cool because it's a beretta 93r
which is almost literally a gucci gun
what it's doing in um early 1980s
ukraine i'm not quite sure
it's uh not something you'd expect to
find there but it is very
cold wary and it is plausible time
period-wise just
all right
just a quick word on the reload
animation on that type 63
it's um a little bit modern day i don't
know any
drill manuals from the 80s that would
have had you knocking the magazine out
[Music]
i just say the the training course is a
nice idea
it's a bit more james bond movie than it
is reality i suspect i don't think
spetsnas as relatively well funded as
they would have been at that time
would have had anything like a
sophisticated setup as this
i'm pretty sure they don't have it now
so but it is cool
and the arcade is a nice touch
can i just say that was a hell of a
knife throw accuracy
power left hand as well that's that's
pretty impressive um in terms of the
ballistics of what we're seeing here i'm
i'm liking what i'm seeing in terms of
uh puffs of dust
sparks of what probably still called
bullets
ricocheting off hard objects i'm not
seeing too much in the way of
silly star wars tracer fire which is
something that gets on my nerves a bit
and
i understand the reason for it you want
to see where your bullets are going but
yeah it has it has a nice sort of gritty
realistic feel to it so far
of course i'm i'm slowly realizing that
this being a highly sophisticated
spatsnass training center
of course there are lots of fun foreign
weapons that they've managed to acquire
just a very quick thing to note on on
the beretta is
how it almost sounds like one shot and
if you've heard of these things fired
for real
it really is that fast
it's three rounds at i'm not sure what
it is thousand rounds per minute
something like that and it is just like
one shot or like an echo of
one shot so they've nailed that it's not
that exaggerated
that you sometimes get with burst fire
weapons
so the next interesting um foreign
weapon that we see picked up here
is the spas 12 and it's an interesting
gun
for the reason that games never depict
which is that it's either
semi-automatic as we're seeing here or
it's pump action
so you can basically change the the
setting of the
pump grip and that disables the
self-loading system so we usually see
one or the other so in the matrix we see
the pump because it looks and sounds
cool
in most games we see semi-automatic
operation
except for half-life where we get magic
shells
being fired from the magazine tube as
well as the barrel but we won't go into
that
modeling-wise it's a good representation
from what i've seen it's got that
classic
bulky look to it and yeah what's as fast
12 what do you want
okay so we've got another weapon change
here we've now got a new primary and
it's
the aks 74u so here is an aks74u
and u the u bit of the name in russian
which i'm not going to attempt
is how short the barrel is so the
modeling of the gun is
is good now the drum magazine is the
interesting thing because
the 74 bit of the name denotes the 5.45
millimeter cartridge which is
correct for this time period we'd expect
the russians to be moving over to the
5.45 cartridge
we don't want that because this one is
fitted with a drum magazine
what i can't do though is show you the
drum magazine
fitted to the gun because they don't fit
there was no issue
5.45 millimeter drum magazine
because this isn't for this gun this is
for the rpk 74 which is a light machine
gun
so what we have here is a fictional 5.45
millimeter
70 odd round drum magazine which of
course is
cool and fun but not really realistic
the other thing i can't help noticing
which is something of a pet hate for me
in period
games is this thing is fitted with an
optical sight set in
1981 around about that time nobody is
running around with optical sights
on their weapons unless they're a sniper
the more i think about it the more this
level is a great showcase
to have lots of different weapons that
wouldn't make any sense otherwise
so we've just seen a player pick up a
barrett 50 caliber
self-loading rifle it's pretty hefty but
you know these guys eat their
wheaties slash wheat picks so unlike me
they'd have no problem
wielding that thing if you watch these
things fired in real life it is possible
for someone with sufficient strength to
pick that up and fire it from the
shoulder
with more than one shot some of the
things we see in games are stretching
credulity in terms of a big heavy
powerful hard recoiling gun
the barrett is actually possible to run
and gun with it's just not something
a soldier would typically do we do have
behind me
a barrett 50. i gather in the game that
there is a suppressed
version of it 50 caliber suppressed
rifles do exist
yeah that's a very hollywood sound
suppressor
sound effect for what is a tremendously
powerful rifle
as i say you can suppress a 50 caliber
rifle it's not gonna sound
like pew pew i'm afraid
so what we're seeing here in single
player bleeding over from multiplayer is
some customization options
um so certain certain weapons have
different stocks different handguards
different sites fitted to them that we'd
expect to see in a multi-player game for
variety and interest and unlocking
things i always think it's a bit weird
when things just crop up in the campaign
and so what we see here is an ak-74 u
where that looks like a gleal ace
it's got a big chunky plastic handguard
it's got an additional magazine well
sticking out the bottom of the receiver
that the
the ak doesn't have and of course the
sight with the mount on it so
fine multiplayer slightly disappointing
perhaps in a single player campaign
i think i need to well i really don't
need to point out actually
that multiple 50 caliber machine gun
rounds
to the head would be problematic
regardless of the helmet that you're
wearing
i mean anecdotally it will sort of cause
your neck to snap back potentially
causing neck injuries
certainly multiple hits the sheer
velocity and mass of those projectiles
is such that they will
breeze through any kind of wearable
armor
so a bit of a half-life flashback here
with the scoped revolver
always fun for gameplay reasons in
reality
scoped revolvers are a competition
thing that's not a scope that's a red
dot sight which is actually more common
so this this has the look of the gun in
the game where you might actually use a
scoped revolver
in real life is in hunting in terms of
what the revolver actually is
don't bother looking because it's not
real it's an interesting combination of
multiple different designs
gives you usually six shots because you
can't fit any more in the cylinder
which means you can up the power of the
gate of the gun in the game
this is why revolvers keep cropping up
in games
because you can make them
proportionately more powerful which they
are in real life
keeping the capacity down so you have to
reload them more regularly
you can make the reload slower and
actually to be fair in the early 80s
revolvers were still very much a thing
militarily
and and in other spheres so we see the
magnum being reloaded
quite rapidly slower than a self-loading
pistol would be depicted in
in the game but relatively quickly and
they're using
speed loaders the six rounds go in as a
unit close it up and carry on firing
which is
perfectly correct recoil is maybe a bit
light
for a magnum revolver but i'm sure this
guy's got some seriously strong wrists
yeah that was that was a curious scene
so we not only have we got
what i'm pretty certain is an
anti-aircraft missile which typically
don't fire against
ground target aren't used against ground
ground targets and won't even fire
without a lock
it's unguided as far as i can tell and
then what really blows my mind is that
we've got three shots there okay so it's
an anti-aircraft missile
but it's an explosive munition with
fragmentation and
blast and all of that and the guy just
shakes it off so
yeah that's the most confusing thing
i've seen so far
sorry i just i just love the uh the
dazed stagger
from being hit with an anti-aircraft
missile just
like shakes it off
so here we've got the the dushka or the
dshk
and probably a dshk m slightly more
modernized version
mount vehicle mounted which they often
are pronounced dushka because it's a bit
of a play in russian on
the name for sweetheart and it's a big
heavy
12.7 millimeter caliber weapon sound is
great
and the look of it is right so far so
good
i'm starting to think it might be a
little bit overpowered people being
thrown left right and centered by it um
it's also not clear what what this thing
is capable of going through or not
i know games like this now are very good
at modeling soft cover hard cover
ricocheting things like that and as we
go down the street
we actually have two apcs called out and
the
the shots are penetrating the armor of
the apc's and
destroying them really what this should
have been is at least a 14.5 millimeter
gun
kpv ppbt to be able to to do serious
damage to an apc they're called armored
personnel carriers for a reason
so that was my breakdown of the very
diverse weapons of the mission
red light green light from call of duty
black ops cold war
i hope you enjoyed it and i hope to see
you again
you